new york's iconic broadway stages have
been dark since mid-march but now a
theater group in pittsfield
massachusetts
is hoping to offer us some help it's
mounting the first
professional union musical production in
this country since a pandemic began
in our new normal series jamie wax shows
us how they're working hard to keep
everybody safe
the musical god spell has been performed
before audiences since 1971
but never quite like this
[Music]
the berkshire theatre group's production
is the only live musical
in the country with a professional union
cast
what's going on here in massachusetts
has captivated the artistic community's
attention
could this be the new normal for theater
going in a pandemic
every inch of precaution you could
imagine being taken is
probably being taken here what i need to
confirm is a phone number for carpet
pricing purposes
costumes sets and the 50-seat outdoor
performance space are all designed to
optimize safety in a ways because of the
restrictions this production has turned
out to be
much more inventive director alan
filderman and choreographer jerry
mcintyre have staged the show under a
whole new set of rules
you have to be six feet apart if you're
speaking
you have to be ten feet apart if you're
singing clear vinyl screens serve as
barriers
it's all for the props and musical
instruments are sanitized
constantly the front row is 25 feet from
the stage
theater goers must have their
temperatures checked and while the cast
must socially distance on stage they're
very close
off stage the cast lives together
they work together they're literally
not allowed to even converse with people
out of their bubble it's a level of
dedication the cast
crew and creators are willing to make at
a time when broadway's shutdown has left
tens of thousands unemployed
we are keenly aware that this has to
work we also know what it means for the
future of musical theater and theater in
general
you have to think outside the box and
bring back culture and art
i'm so excited to be back in the theater
[Music]
high stakes for high art creative
director kate mcguire
on opening night there we were all
socially distanced and as separate as
you could possibly be
but at least we were still all together
seeing live theater
and at the end the feeling was
absolutely overwhelming
for cbs this morning jamie wax new york
yeah boy i love it when people can
figure out a way to make it work
yes like they said you have to think
outside the box to bring back culture
and art you have to think about outside
the box to bring back many things
but when you can figure it out you know
what guys i think we're going to get to
the point where
partitions won't look weird that's how
it is
i agree with you i'm so glad they made
the effort to do this and the minute i
started hearing them singing i just was
like i realized how deeply i missed it
you know live theater it's just
it's it's great that they've done it
there's nothing like it